Speaker 1: In Georgia, radical Republican
Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Green
is now being asked by the feds to account for
three point five million dollars in political
donations made to her that she has not itemized.
This is a very, very important Newsweek article,
says the Federal Election Commission, the FEC, has
asked Marjorie Taylor Greene for more information
about three and a half million dollars in
contributions to her reelection campaign. In
two filings posted to the FEC website Monday and
surfaced on Twitter by Georgia Public Broadcasting
reporter Stephen Fowler on Tuesday, the
congresswoman's husband, Perry Green, who is also
her treasurer draining the swamp, Wright was asked
to provide additional details about donations the
campaign received during the first two quarters
of twenty twenty one. Look at these numbers.
Between January and March, the Green campaign
received two point five million in an itemized
donations from undisclosed donors, while the
campaign received another nearly million dollars
in an itemized donations between April and June,
the campaign reported a total of more than four
and a half million dollars in donations during
the same period. Candidates are not. Look at this.
Candidates are not legally obliged to itemize
donations or disclose the identity of donors for
contributions that total under two hundred dollars
for an election cycle. For donations that do need
to be itemized, campaigns must supply details,
including name of the donor address, occupation,
employer and the date of the donation. The FEC
has given the Green campaign until October 12
to provide clarification about the three and
a half million to comply with FEC rules. The
campaign must either provide information
about the donors or show the money came
from small donors only from at least seventeen
thousand six hundred and thirty individuals,
contributing no more than one hundred ninety nine
dollars ninety nine cents each. It is conceivable
mathematically that this was only through small
donations, but it is not particularly likely.
So she pretended to be about draining the swamp.
And yet she is the swamp on itemized donations.
Husband, his campaign treasurer, anybody sick
of hearing about these stories? And then nothing
ever actually ends up happening. Like everything
these people do, everything these people do. Yes.
Is a grift. I'm still wondering, how did she get
away with declaring to homestead exemptions at the
same time on her taxes? Do you even remember
that story? That was was it six months ago?
Was it 12 months ago? You're only allowed to
have one homestead exemption or declaration.
Marjorie Taylor Green had to. And we discovered
that it was being investigated. I've heard nothing
since. What's going on with that? Could
this be as simple as Marjorie Taylor Green
just is using her campaign donations as
a personal slush fund and used it for
personal expenses? Could it be that simple?
Hopefully we'll find out more. And she has
until October 12th to disclose the oranges
or the origins about her, your preference
and usage of those donations. We will try
to follow it. Unfortunately, too often the
story goes nowhere and we never hear about
it again. We'll be covering these stories as
well as updates to other stories from earlier
this week on the David Pakman show Instagram.
Make sure you're following us there at David
Pakman show and follow me at David Pakman.